go now live to Brussels where the
Ryanair chief executive Michael O'Leary
is waiting to speak to us Michael
welcome to you you've cut capacity to
Italy by quarter from mid-march until
early April he said only your Italian
roots where demand has fallen
yeah good afternoon
Ian good to talk to you principally to
deliberately declining bookings in the
last week has been focused on the
Italian domestic routes and routes to
and from northern Italy there are some
minor cuts in some other areas but
mainly it's focused on Italy and we've
taken out about a day's worth of flying
in the last two weeks of March and the
first week of April at the moment we
keep the second week of April under
review but at this point in time we
don't see any impact on those bookings
in the second and third week of April
which is the easter school holidays it
looks at this point in time my people
will continue to travel during that
period so it'll be the three weeks prior
to Easter there might be a little bit
discretionary travel after Easter and
but it's an evolving situation we
managed on a day late to day to day
basis so really you see Daman being
depressed for any quite a short period
of time really it depends on how it
develops over the next number of weeks I
mean I'm reasonably optimistic I think
it would be reasonably short-lived
remember we're coming out into the
spring/summer period in Europe that
itself will help to limit the spread of
a flu-like virus like at The Cove in 19
and people are obviously there's been a
reduction in the short term in travel
people aren't taking sense of the
measure I think the good thing about the
outbreak across many European countries
in the last week or two has been you're
getting much more sensible government
information being communicated
hand-washing taking sensible precautions
if you feel you have the symptoms of a
flu self isolate those kind of sensible
cam measures will be much more effective
in combating the spread of kovat 19 then
for example cancelling football matches
or big public events so I think we're
calling for calm yes there would be a
decline short term and travel but I
think it would be reasonably short-lived
and I hope it would be reasonably
short-lived
what kind of no-shows have you seen
lately on flights we've seen no-shows
over the last number of days of upwards
of up to 50% on particularly some of the
Italian domestic routes I mean Italy has
been the country most affected
by this there has been a significant
disruption to economic activity in Italy
we think that's likely to spread for the
next week or two which is why again we
think we've taken out some a sensible
reduction in a small number of flights
in the last two weeks of March the first
week of April but we would hope to see
you know some of the hysteria taken out
of the coverage of the kovat 19 virus
outbreak that we've seen over the last
week more accurate government and chief
w-h-o information being communicated and
help us to fend off some of the frankly
lunacy that gets communicated on social
media you think people are losing their
heads a bit then look it's the natural
thing you know people always panic they
overreact you know if you look at the
numbers of people thankfully and even in
the UK and a population of 65 million
people what are we got today 51 people
who are have confirmed cases I mean the
numbers here are tiny that does require
a proportion at a sensible and
proportionate response it does require
government information both in the UK
and all other EU countries but it also
requires people to be sensible Amanah
near the conference the a40 conference
today in Brussels were all hand-washing
using disinfectants taking those
sensible measures and but there's no
reason why you know sensible economic
activity can't and will continue but
whatever happens you know you've been
here I've been here before we had 9/11
we've had SARS we've had these kind of
pestilences visited on the industry and
the economy generally before they're
generally usually short-lived and then
people will return to normal pretty
quickly the key challenge for our
industry is you know will there be
casualties in the next number of weeks
if there's a big drop-off in bookings
and some airlines are clearly under
pressure in terms of cash flow and we
think it will lead to further failures
in the next number of weeks Mike you
mentioned 9/11 there I mean the stock
price reaction for companies like
Ryanair IAG easyJet's I mean it's not
dissimilar than what we saw after
September the 11th of investors gone a
bit over the top I suspect so but as you
know yourself you know the market tends
towards you you've hedge funds in there
you have a you know excessive volumes of
people going short going long you see
much more
in the stock market these days on you
know short term you slow like Frankie if
you're not selling your shares it
doesn't matter we take a long-term view
of these kind of issues in Ryanair we
are still investing in new aircraft
we're still waiting for the delivery of
the 737 max aircraft later this year Ian
in fact Airbus called up last week and
want to know could we take some new
aircraft earlier than 2025 and we said
as always if the price is right we'd buy
a new aircraft today tomorrow next week
you know Ryanair would be here we have
four billion in cash on the balance
sheet we will work our way through this
over the next number of weeks a number
of months whatever it is and we will
still be Europe's largest and
fastest-growing airline but before
during and after the cove in nineteen
out break now you mentioned events being
canceled obviously you're a great man of
the turf will you still be going to
Cheltenham as usual issue if it's on I
certainly hope to be there I was also
hoping to go to a couple of Irish rugby
internationals but unfortunately the
Irish government do I think in an
overreaction canceled the the Italian
rugby match in Dublin this week there's
still two and a half thousand Italian
rugby supporters travelling to Dublin
for the weekend anyway so cancelling the
event is you know not been a sensible or
proportionate measure I'm pleased to see
the rest of the Six Nations matches in
Twickenham and in Paris are going ahead
and I'm very hopeful the children will
go ahead next week and that you know the
less disruption we have to people's
lives and people's normal economic
activity the better that's the I think
they don't think the key role government
can play at this is can communicate
information calmly sensibly
let's not have panicked or you know
irrational panic measures